одну за одну південь о 5-го лізи з
берлінського залазиш нового до зали
на параду дні нового року місця
наповниться вигляд виду віджиму c до води
знати і диким адже трохи team приїжджати
сюди люди не вдів запису 1
терористичної атаки прибрали не
обидва частіше тут я поліції цьому я
підкоряюсь від рук і безтурботніше, проте і
озираюсь на підлозі кіно раунд я мій друг
витончено вич і тебе напав на нас ти3
бабу-то насторожі і приспівів, а чого і
масти добра 1 км і на мага йому
синдикатами stella palace cucine людей
мій ну-ка і мати і несучи на випадів ще
стануть загалом нічого не дати більше
розслабленими
ширяє бранденбурзькі ворота ми багата
туристи в тих хто знає хотів би
провести тут на горі щось легкове і
спробувала не трубу їх чи можна атака з
термінів передумаєш і після атак заходи
б спектру badly не посилав їм теж тут
за глини боюся обама ти впав на несть
оптимізм до продовжила ти ж ти за даними
та туристичних компаній булок кілька
видно на увазі готельних та морил однак
нині місяця у центрі берліну продовжують
брюс нього ти страшний травня нам і cargo ти
так одум кабан набряк і наша терор пара
може
влада місця посилала заходи без пеку за
крима і нами series 2 оного ярмарок
дісталося а трагедія
максиму нам ожив його за ват це нібито
тут навколо буду б то ні блоком пішло в
жадібним антощуком вона змогла всюди за них від
і
all ще тихіше може стати основу лісів
[музика]
теракт у бар і день зради у завальний
стала недуга стеки
однак bitches людей хочеш жити і треба
чи нормальним же team зовсім одне
навісна стоїть з від кого і гарантії за
христом